hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to kindergarten now a lot of
you guys have been requesting this game
and as far as I know
the only objective in this game is to
survive and that seemed strange
considering it's a game about little
children attending kindergarten but I've
played stranger games and I have no idea
what I'm doing here
press down to make money press up to put
money back what's down take my Oh make
money ok well I'm gonna take everything
out of my piggy bank and yeah alright
okay am I going to kindergarten am I
ready to start another game kindergarten
yeah sure okay I don't know what else
I'm gonna do I boob lady are you doing I
smell money yes someone is definitely
carrying more than three dollars around
here hey hey kid you carried any cash no
you don't know me I carry nothing no
don't lie to me I know when I smell
money
give me half or else no way look kid I
don't have time to argue with this with
you give it to me or you're dead meat
like your own money oh oh ow ow ow ow oh
oh oh god oh god oh god I didn't know
that I didn't know that I didn't know
that oh god no no no no
oh it's optional okay you know and I'll
just I'll carry 290 I don't have more
than three dollars butch or whatever
your name is I'm pear 52 third another
day you'd know it I know no I am making
a pentagram in my place I think screw
that kid I'm busy I'll screw offic I
guess hello hi my friends call me nugget
are they what if I had any nuggets no no
love or friendship suits Billy went
missing what happened to Billy
Oh Ellie's missing Gordon ah get mrs.
Billy but nugget cannot help him now it
is too late you're Bill Berry is nugget
does not know nugget knows who knows who
knows your question upset poor nugget
you push too hard okay
Oh much better what we were talking
about Billy who I don't know what you're
talking about you're speaking normally
now oh we were not the principal is
forbidding me from speaking about it and
if you press me any further I'll report
you to him all right I need the book no
you don't enjoy your trip to the
principal's office
whatever nugget Oh food lady now the
principal just called me he wants to see
you in his office
what didn't you in this little weirdo do
well that's a good question
another good question is can he speak
telepathically to the principal because
this is a growing concern of mine well
keep going then the principal is an
impatient man oh so impatient oh I so
I've been told that you're feeling sad
about Billy
who told you oh you know we're just uh
gets around you know it doesn't matter
how I know that I do know see okay so
all about it that's all this is about
right Billy's missing and it's making
you sad you're not trying to find him or
anything you're just sad he's gone right
hook okay that makes us a whole lot
easier so here's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna give you something and I want you
to take it whenever you're feeling sad
about Billy what is it just a little
something I ordered for this exact
reason here take one whenever you miss
Billy too much okay you're giving me
pills just don't tell anyone you got
them from me
the hall monitor is waiting to take you
back to class please head outside okay
principal I've got taking pills all
right enjoy them why do you have to
Gus's here walk if you hook up guns here
there's some papers and a monster man
card here
all right I'll take the card I guess new
hint unlocked
what the [ __ ] is happening
I think this rug seems a little out of
place seems like there's blood if there
keeps the rug yeah it seems like there's
some scraping and going on here
principal I got a bad feeling about this
principal I I don't even know how to
count to three teacher I'm not learning
anything in this school I think maybe
it's bad place for me I don't miss Billy
but I miss my family
welcome back welcome back boob lady I
hope everything turned out okay with the
principal everything is fine say the
principal didn't happen to give you
anything did he he gave me some pills a
lucky day you wouldn't mind if your luck
would be my guess do you miss Billy I
guess we all just be pill someday good
boy go oh that's nice thank you for that
go on and enjoy the rest of your morning
time I know oh okay you want to seem
like you got some extra boob death dose
up on this medicine right see ya bye
again okay hey don't go snooping around
and you know what I don't really care do
what you want okay all right continue
snooping then this Jerome's cubby
there's a strange device in here okay oh
that did for me but okay what this this
is Nuggets cubby there's appears to be a
negative sub sword in here I'll leave
that this a knife who's bugs cubby
that's a knife getting caught with this
would give me in serious trouble I'll
take it
whatever North Carrick Lili's cubby
looking for clues for her missing
brother Billy oh jesus said okay I don't
want to take the money because then I'd
have more than three bucks and I don't
want that Michael do you think I want to
be your morning buddy good point
hello sorry sweetie but I'm spending my
morning time with my boyfriend whatever
Cindy okay hello nugget does not wish to
spend mourning time with you nugget it's
very busy
see what are you busy with you're
curious about the waves of little get
interesting perhaps you could be of some
use to nugget nugget given me with a
magnifying glass do this will now get
before the next bell rings and you will
be rewarded
alright okay alright I guess I'll get
you this steal this magnifying glass for
you am I gonna be rewarded now have you
found the items nugget seeks excellent
bucket is pleased you may have this
monster mint card
nugget is quite fond of it okay now
beyond nugget has important things to
attend I don't really do the whole
morning buddy thing anymore my brother
Billy was normally my buddy but he's
missing what where's Billy I want to
take a pill good you know you're not
cool after talk to me let alone be my
morning buddy like latias gonna hook me
up with a sweet yo-yo all right
teacher I have no morning buddy go into
a morning time before my high wears off
suitable model always so bouncy what do
you want to be my morning buddy well I
ain't got time for that nonsense so
unless you're buying or selling
something get lost
wanna sell something what do you got
yeah Bob tells whoa whole bottle of
those things my guy who likes him is
gonna be thrilled
I'll give you four dollars for the whole
thing all right
what are you doing business with you
gonna buy something new guy yo-yo
screwdriver cigarettes who are committed
things I'll buy a sweet yo-yo yeah do
you know about these things but Rome
loves him all right well I have a oh I'm
out of actions oh okay well I guess I'm
done okay kids that's a lunch Bell let's
go down to the cap dear for a nutritious
meal of blood and Billy slop how
exciting
[Laughter]
but that's really funny to be just this
lady hammering away whatever the slop is
how you doing there honey
what I'm tasting nutritious slob uh
what's in it it's an old family recipe
lots of herbs and spices and salt and
about 89 percent of the principal secret
ingredient it's nothing percent is alive
I don't know how I know that given that
I am a kindergartener who barely knows
how to count to three
it's not that much supposedly it keeps
the slop and regulates with the
government's new health standards what's
the bigger ingredient I can tell you
that it's a secret also I have no idea
what it is either you're feeding us a
seasoned mystery ingredient but the
seasoning is so good it's the best part
I'm not eating it well that's your call
can't make you eat it
I'd love it if you did just fine move
along all right fine then above it's
kids from from a shimmy the janitor here
biscuit balls use your biscuit ball here
get a mother hot biscuit all my own
recipe come up with it after a little
tension and that happened recently yeah
uh-huh
what's in them whatever is in a biscuit
and a little something extra
it's it's worth it Wooper tease me
oh come on it won't kill you they're a
buck apiece quite a deal if I do say so
myself
I'm sure your little friend Cindy would
love to dry one what I guess there's a
crazy man
just gonna tell Jay he'll go on and give
her home here he'll love it you're
you're being really creepy about this
I'm all he's creepy
let's give her an amnestic did you drug
it or something what course not I'm not
that kind Jenner this come has something
a bit more entertaining all right fine
you know what
oh boy whatever quite a deal but say so
myself
I'm Shirley
can be fun okay fine okay six Andy was
that you Cindy
or is this Cindy which one of you Cindy
you Cindy sorry sweetie this spot is
reserved for my boyfriend because it was
ugly Lily oiler janitor wants you to try
this
there's no I I'm eating anything that
creep me I wouldn't eat it but why did I
buy it then but I spent a dollar on this
that I stole by selling a magnifying
glass or whatever the hell I did sell a
bottle of pills that the principal gave
me no nemesis with poor nugget nugget
does not have any friends you say that
like a statement you don't say that like
you're whining about it you say like a
statement I figured you'd be seeing me
around pop is no good and I don't think
anyone is brave enough to drive biscuit
from the janitor dumb old man can't even
spell it right all right well you got
I've got a biscuit you want that i buy
something from you salad McLobster Emil
never mind okay
I'm just gonna leave now and try to find
lily I guess what the hell is this all
right Lily
Hank stop you can't leave it - lunch is
over all right okay - cool sorry go eat
something that it's not what happy I
have to eat something
well if you're slinging slop I guess
I'll take it yeah oh uh check out the
bathroom
oh I'm not allowed to any of you kidding
down the hall maybe you could do me a
little something if you wanted me to
look the other way well I seem to have
misplaced my glasses these old eyes
can't read the menu without him see if
he can find a pair lying around and I'll
let you out
there anything else I can do well that
mopey little girl's been paying me to
let her out I don't see why you can't
get the same deal I'll try to find the
glasses I guess the van the trash can
are they in the swap
all right find that jz- friends live
wave um find somewhere else' kissing ah
sir have you seen a pair of glasses
vegan your boyfriend Wow
talking about the bar low I'll make you
deal luck I'll give you the biscuit ball
for free don't worry
it's vegan I'll also throw in one of the
mums men cars all you gotta make sure he
eats it where are you say the [ __ ] can I
come back here when she's down did I
didn't ah this doesn't feel right
there's no way I'm eating anything that
creep made well she didn't want it did
she eat it not yet
what am I supposed to do am I supposed
to hide it
what am I supposed to do oh man I have
no idea how about a salad and I'll put
it in there we're gonna cut some fat
it's totally healthy vegan choice
pleasure doing business with ya all
right is there any way I can like drive
an inventory system getting uh get a
magnifying glass one I don't need that
okay all right ah I can I just pay you
money to go out into the bathroom
because I feel like that's what I need
la la la la la la la la la two bucks
okay oh I'm always happy to help a child
in need
keeps me young now run along I didn't
see nothing okay thanks thank you lunch
lady keep hammering the way whatever the
hell you're hammering away at because
super weird thank God hello go away kid
I'll get in trouble the principal hears
you all right fine ma'am what are you
doing this is door to the principal's
office
what are you doing why are you just
standing outside the principal's office
are you looking for Billy
Kimsey something behind the air-vent but
I need something to unscrew with damn it
I could have bought a screwdriver ah
yeah oh right locked and then the
bathroom which is where I get some
uh-huh you're not supposed to be in here
yeah I'll take you to the principal that
is this well I'm not cigarette if you
had some I'd be willing to let you off
major bummer man
looks like we got to go visit the
principal ah man you can't just be
running around the school during once
you should know better
I'm sorry me too what I don't know what
what the hell ha ha excuse me why did
you shoot me why did you shoot me and
why are you sorry about it why are you
like a burden like oh I have to put what
are you warm fish by some reason in your
mind that's the only logical conclusion
to solve your problems like I'm sorry I
have to do this there's literally no
other oh man that's hilarious okay so
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode I didn't make it very far
at all but oh and apparently I didn't
get any my collectibles because I didn't
finish the day out well that is sad but
now I know a little more about how to
beat this so maybe I'll play another
episode to sell but let me know we think
down the comments below there's a lot of
different ways to go about this deny
apparently I'm not doing it correctly so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]